I'm just honored to be mentioned on a legacy show,
like "Broad City",
please welcome, Abbi Jacobson.
(audience applauding)
I'm not kidding,
I would like to thank you for the cred.
No, it is my absolute honor.
We talked about you all the time in the writer's room.
It was our pleasure to put you on the show
as much as humanly possible.
So yeah, I haven't seen that in a second,
I miss doing that.
Now your beautiful partner,
the great Ilana Glazer is about to be a mom.
Yes.
How is that?
It's incredible.
She's been talking about this for a long time.
She came over here with her partner,
and they told me they're so excited,
she's going to be such an incredible mom.
She has a lot of like mom energy already, I think.
She's very motherly,
but it's just been really adorable to see her belly grow,
(Abbi coughing)
Sorry guys.
But I wish I was just getting choked up,
but there was just something in my throat.
(Drew laughing)
We were in the same city for a while and now we're not
and so I just get a lot of FaceTimes,
and pictures of her belly growing, but it's,
I mean Ilana is like this little person anyway,
it's so cute to watch her get bigger.
Well, and you are really close with your mom, right?
I am, yes.
I'm seeing my mom tomorrow for Mother's Day early.
I love that you're close with your mom.
What are you guys gonna do?
I don't even know.
We'll just hang out,
going to have a dinner in the backyard I think
with my brother and his kids,
I got her a really cute shirt and some socks,
but don't tell her until she opens it.
I won't tell her a thing.
and now you are adapting "A League of Their Own".
I mean, how cool is this?
And I heard you actually got to talk to Penny Marshall
before she departed this planet with her amazing gifts
that she'd be stowed upon it.
It was pretty incredible.
I mean, Will Graham asked me to do this project with him
and we got the opportunity
to jump on the phone with her really to get her blessing
and to just ask her about the experience and.
Okay, but that's perfect.
That like, what was penny Marshall's blessing?
What did it sound like?
Paint the scene.
I got it.
Okay, perfect.
She goes, well umm,
go and do it already and go and do it,
and I was like okay, that was it.
Yeah, she was so sweet and supportive.
You know, this is like,
it's a very much a re-imagining of the film.
We are doing sort of a re-examining of what it was like.
We're telling a lot of stories of what it was like
for women who wanted to,
who had the dream to play baseball
so yes, it's like a door opens for a lot of white women
and white passing women
that get on the league that we all know from the film.
But what about the black women
who were not allowed to try out
and who had to sort of carve their own path
to play baseball?
It's also a really queer story,
which I know it's wild to imagine that
women playing professional baseball might have been queer,
but they were,
and that sort of wasn't part of the film.
So we're really trying to keep the spirit
and the joy that the film has.
And just open up the lens to tell a lot more stories
and a lot more of the realities
of what was really going on in 1943.
Okay I have to talk to you before we go
about your new film that I'm so obsessed with
The Mitchells vs. The Machines.
I want to tell you one of the reasons why I love it so much
is because it was one of the first films that I'm seeing
that feels like it represents what my family is really like.
And I just thank you so much for making this movie
for families out there.
And I would love to show a clip
of The Mitchells vs. the Machines,
I just I'm so excited.
Play it safe?
When Rick Mitchell brought a live non-neutered,
feral possum into our home, did he play it safe?
No, he named him Gus and made him a member of the family
and we all got rabies at one time.
But now we're immunized and we're stronger for it.
(audience laughing)
Abbi I'm so honored to hang out with you.
The Mitchells vs. The Machines is available now on Netflix
and it's my highest recommendation
for families to get together and watch this awesome,
real, humorous, bad-ass adventure that you've made.
Thank you so much.
Thank you so much for having me.
What a pleasure really.
(upbeat music)